[Musik]
der hat zehn sie
überall auf der welt
und gleicht
rund um die uhr
filmen kameras
packende
extrem ruhig bleibt ruhig
furchterregende
naturphänomene was sollen wir tun guck
dir das an man ist wie gelähmt
es gibt kein entkommen
das ist reality tv sie glauben sie
kennen das wetter diese experten
erklären was wirklich passiert das
wasser fließt in den wirbel mit
den spektakulärsten wetter videos der
welt
stellen sie sich einen tornado vor so
breit wie die erde er besteht aus
wirbelnden gasen ist 40 millionen grad
heiß und 300.000 kilometer pro stunde
schnell
wetter das nicht von dieser welt ist
das wetter im weltraum ist gewaltig und
wunderschön und gleichzeitig schrecklich
plötzlich sieht man die erde mit anderen
augen
das ist die oberfläche der sonne
150 millionen kilometer von uns entfernt
betörend und bedrohlich zugleich
wir sprechen bei solchen phänomenen von
sonnen tornados sie sehen aus wie
gewöhnliche tornados sind aber ganz
anders auf der erde entstehen tornados
durch das zusammenspiel von
luftströmungen feuchtigkeit und
temperatur unterschieden sondern
thrombus werden dagegen durch heißes
plasma und magnetische strahlung erzeugt
die sonne besteht aus plasma und das ist
aufgeladene materie die magnetfelder
treten aus der oberfläche heraus und
befördern dabei plasma nach oben sehr
heißes aufgeladen das material das in
die sonnenatmosphäre geschossen wird
dabei beschleunigt sich die rotation wie
bei einem eiskunstläufer der seine arme
anzieht man kann sogar sehen wie die
spitze breiter wird
in diesem video sehen sie einen
feuertornado so groß wie die erde
wahnsinn
wenn man das video sieht könnte man
glauben dass es sich hier um ein sehr
seltenes ereignis handelt einer studie
zufolge toben jedoch rund um die uhr
11.000 stürme gleichzeitig über die
sonnenoberfläche
bedenken sie nur welchen schaden ein
tornado auf der erde anrichten kann und
wie kleine ist im vergleich zu so einem
sonnensturm der obendrein so heiß wie
die sonne ist
silvester 2013 gelingen dem solar
dynamics observatory der nasa wieso
unglaublichen aufnahmen von eruptionen
auf der oberfläche der sonne
[Musik]
wegen solcher bilder bin ich sonnen
physiker geworden
dieses video zeigt eine sonneneruption
150 millionen kilometer weit weg aber
mit unserer technologie fühlte sich an
als stünden wir direkt daneben die
menschen sind schon ziemlich clever
die sonne besteht aus heißem plasma
elektrische strömungen in ihrem inneren
erzeugen ein magnetfeld die eruptionen
entstehen wenn sich aufgebaute
magnetische energie plötzlich entlädt
solche eruptionen sind tausendmal wenn
nicht millionen mal stärker als eine
atombombe klar sehen sie schön aus sie
hauen uns regelrecht um aber wir können
uns trotzdem nicht vorstellen was für
eine power dahinter steckt
starke sonneneruptionen treten in zyklen
von ungefähr elf jahren auf 2012
verfehlte eine der größten
sonneneruptionen überhaupt die erde nur
knapp eine woche vorher war die erde
noch an der stelle die voll getroffen
wurde
[Musik]
den physikern wird erst jetzt klar wie
knapp einer katastrophe entgangen sind
ein solch massiver ausstoß von sonnen
plasma hätte sämtliche satelliten und
stromnetze außer gefecht setzen können
welche folgen hätte ein sonnensturm für
die erde
[Musik]
so eine sonneneruption kann unsere
satelliten beschädigen sie werden mit so
viel energie aufgeladen dass sie
ausfallen für uns hätte das verheerende
folgen auf der erde könnten kabel
schmelzen und transistoren durch knallen
die stromversorgung würde
zusammenbrechen bei einem richtig großen
ding vielleicht sogar weltweit
eigentlich müssten wir uns besser darauf
vorbereiten aber leider lassen sich
sonneneruptionen kaum vorhersagen
wir wissen nicht wie stark sie seien und
welchen kurs sie nehmen werden eine
verlässliche vorhersage mit ausreichend
vorlaufzeit lässt sich da kaum machen
[Musik]
sonneneruptionen mögen große
zerstörerische kraft besitzen aber sie
sind auch für einige wunderschöne natur
phänomene verantwortlich
polarlichter entstehen wenn elektrisch
geladene teilchen des sonnenwinds in den
oberen schichten der erdatmosphäre auf
sauerstoff und stickstoff atome treffen
und diese ionisieren das heißt positiv
aufladen
jedes chaos sorgt für eine andere farbe
sauerstoff erzeugt ein grünliches gelb
oder rotes licht während stickstoff
blaues licht erzeugt es kann einen
wunderschönen regenbogen effekt geben es
sieht fast wie ein schimmernder vorhang
aus wenn die sonnenstrahlung mit der
junos fähre der erde reagiert
[Musik]
1,4 milliarden kilometer von der sonne
entfernt entstanden diese umwerfenden
bilder eines hurricanes auf dem saturn
aufgenommen von der cassini raumsonden
der nasa
man sieht hier einen haken am pol des
planeten
ein fantastisches bild ein cooler wirbel
in bewegung die falschfarben
veranschaulichen die höhe da wollten wir
[Musik]
wissen immer noch nicht wie das
funktioniert auf der erde entstehen
hurricanes übergroßen gewässern soweit
wir wissen gibt es auf dem saturn aber
keine gewässer
noch hat die wissenschaft keine
erklärung für die entstehung solcher
hurricanes gefunden ihre gewaltige kraft
es dagegen kein geheimnis
wenn ich ein bild von hurrikan katrina
neben diesen hier läge sieht es auf den
ersten blick so aus als wären beide etwa
gleich groß in wirklichkeit passt unsere
erde zweimal da rein
der hurrikan auf dem saturn hat
windgeschwindigkeiten von 500 kilometer
pro stunde unsere schnellsten hurricanes
erreichen nur die hälfte
auf der erde wurde ein sturm mit solchen
geschwindigkeiten glatt 150 kilometer
küste verwüstet da stimmen wir kein haus
mehr als hätte man eine atombombe
abgeworfen
[Musik]
wolken sind nicht so kuschelig wie sie
aussehen
von mächtigen stürmen bis zu
fremdartigen formationen in den wolken
steckt mehr als man auf den ersten blick
vermittelt
2013 filmte der fotograf mike oppland
ski eine gewaltige supersturm zelle in
der nähe von booker texas das ist eines
meiner lieblings videos der super zellen
studieren möchte er sollte es sich
ansehen
ein klassisches beispiel für eine super
zelle
man sieht die rotierende wolken walze im
unteren teil die aussieht wie ein
raumschiff
darüber den großen langen amboss das
sind riesige wolken massen die nach oben
gewirbelt wurden und jetzt nicht mehr
weiter aufsteigen können
eine super zelle ist im grunde ein sehr
starkes gewitter mit ihren rotierenden
auffinden sorgt sie für extreme
wetterphänomene
eine super zelle kann ein tornado
erzeugen aber auch hagel oder scheer
winde mit geschwindigkeiten bis zu 150
kilometer pro stunde die gewaltige
schäden anrichten können
eine super celle ist die extremste art
von gewitter
der zeitraffer macht diese bilder zu
etwas besonderes sie sind so
faszinierend weil man wirklich sehen
kann wie sich die struktur aufbaut und
wie sich das licht verändert
man sieht wie sich das ganze ding dreht
und versteht warum solche
wetterphänomene so fantastisch so
aufregend und dynamisch sind
manche wolken kommen von oben als wären
sie nicht von dieser welt andere
schleichen sich von unten heran so wie
hier am grand canyon wo sich ein
seltenes naturschauspiel in all seiner
pracht entfaltet
das ist nicht alltäglich dass zu erleben
ist wie ein lottogewinn ein
unglaublicher anblick
das nennt man in version nebel wie in
einem haus in dem der keller immer der
kälteste raum ist und der dachboden der
wärmste
unten im canyon ist es etwas kühler und
feucht die feuchtigkeit kondensiert und
dabei entstehen die wolken oder der
nebel
nebel ist nichts anderes als eine
schicht wolke am boden wenn sie wissen
wollen wie sich eine wolke anfühlt gehen
sie raus in den nebel in dem nebel sehen
sie die hand vor augen nicht wenn sie
auf einer klippe stehen lautet mein
vorschlag schön dort zu bleiben bis der
nebel abzieht denn ein falscher schritt
und das war der nebel nacht ein
buchstäblich blind
bis zum nachmittag hat sich der nebel
aufgelöst dank der sonne ist er so
schnell verschwinden wie er gekommen war
fremdartige erscheinungen prangen 2013
am himmel über der wüste in neuseeland
es sind sogenannte lantiq klares wolken
die eher selten auftreten
wenn die leute diese relativ kleinen
linsenförmigen wollten sehen wie wie
gestapelt erscheinen halten sie sie oft
für ufos so sehen sie auch auf
[Musik]
diese wolkenschichten entstehen wenn die
luft sich über den bergen ausdehnt und
bis zum kondensation punkt abkühlt
danach lagern sich weitere luftschichten
oben ab so dass es am ende aussieht wie
ein stapel pancakes
solange sich in der umgebung der wollte
die windrichtung oder die feuchtigkeit
nicht ändern bleibt sie an ihrem platz
sie erinnern an fliegende untertassen
kurz vor der landung nur ohne die
blinkenden lichter
aber wenn es wie eine wolke aussieht
dann ist es wohl auch eine
[Musik]
wolken sind längst nicht alle gleich und
nur wenige sind so spektakulär wie diese
rollende wolke die von einer frauenrolle
texas gefilmt wurde
was für ein hammer video
das ist eine roll cloud eine böen walze
und zwar ein echtes prachtexemplar
wahrscheinlich wird in zukunft jeder
meteorologie professor seinen studenten
diese bilder zeigen und sagen hier haben
wir eine roll cloud besser geht's nicht
[Musik]
diese rollende bewegungen entsteht für
gewöhnlich denn über wasserflächen zwei
luftströmungen aufeinandertreffen
clouds sind eine isolierte erscheinung
sie entstehen wenn gewitterböen warme
und feuchte luft zum aufsteigen bringen
die feuchtigkeit kondensiert eine wolke
bildet sich und wird vom sturm zu einer
walze zusammengerollt und horizontal
ausgerichtet
man kann sich gut vorstellen dass die
menschen in früheren zeiten diese wolken
für ein zeichen der götter hielten
oder von außerirdischen
eine ganz eigene begegnung der dritten
art haben ein vater und sein sohn
während eines angel trips ihr video
wurde zum internet hit vater und sohn
gehen angeln und plötzlich sehen sie
diese gewaltige wand auf sich zukommen
wenn ich auch dieses boot gewesen wäre
hätte ich mir doch ein wenig sorgen
gemacht
kennen sie den namen dieses wetter
wunders
atreg zions nebel
das war im mai zu dieser jahreszeit
legen oft warme und feuchte luftmassen
über dem wasser das selbst aber noch
recht kühl ist so kühlt sich die luft
über dem wasser ab die feuchtigkeit
kondensiert und bildet diese enormen
nebelbank
das ist eine der spektakulärsten die ich
je gesehen habe
auf zu einem weit im faszinierenden
wetterereignis
während einer zugfahrt in russland
gelangen einem passagier diese aufnahmen
das phänomen nennt sich neben sonne zwei
nette kleine regenbögen an den seiten
und dazu auch der komplette halo
lichteffekt
man sieht einen lichtbogen und zwei
helle punkte links und rechts von der
sonne das sind die neben sonnen sie
treten immer paarweise auf
im prinzip reden wir hier von sehr hohen
wolkenschichten die aus eiskristallen
bestehen diese kristalle sind so dünn
dass man sie nicht sehen kann
das licht bricht sich an den
eiskristallen und so wird dieser
optische effekt erzielt
die dünnen eis plättchen richten sich
horizontal in der luft aus und dienen
dem sonnenlicht als prisma das licht
wird in einem bestimmten winkel
gebrochen und erzeugt eine art
regenbogeneffekt
die meisten internet videos zeigen
phänomene die große zerstörung
verursacht deshalb ist es schön ab und
zu mal einen neben sonne zu sehen
sonnenstrahlen die in eiskristallen
gebrochen werden das ist wenigstens mal
ein schönes bild das guckt man sich gern
an
[Musik]
jetzt kommt etwas das man auch nicht
alle tage sieht ein phänomen namens mond
regenbogen
[Musik]
er wird durch nicht erzeugt das von der
mondoberfläche
reflektiert wird das geschieht
normalerweise nur in hellen
vollmondnächten
kurz nach sonnenuntergang oder kurz vor
sonnenaufgang
und was passiert wenn man einen
regenbogen auf den kopf stellen
[Musik]
ein cirka um 10 ital bogen ist ein ganz
besonderes spektakel
er entsteht wenn sich das sonnenlicht in
eiskristallen bricht während der
betrachter bei normalen regenbögen die
sonne im rücken hat verlaufen zur 15
ital bögen kreisförmig um den himmel
szene herum also ganz oben am himmel
der continental bögen und neben sonnen
sind nicht die einzigen phänomene die
entstehen wenn sonnenstrahlen auf
eiskristalle treffen dies ist ein feuer
regenbogen eine atemberaubende
erscheinung
es ist weder feuer noch regenbogen und
ziemlich cool das licht wird von
eiskristallen gebrochen
bei einem regenbogen ist es so ähnlich
aber mit regentropfen
hier handelt es sich um zirruswolken
also wolken in sehr großer höhe
die sondern muss in einem sehr hohen
winkel stehen alles muss perfekt passen
und das kommt nur sehr selten vor
sieht aus wie zwischen den wolken
[Musik]
du musst am richtigen ort sein und die
sonne muss an der richtigen stelle seien
das spektakel das du dargeboten bekommst
diese farben einfach cool
der legende nach wartet am ende des
regenbogens ein topf voll gold aber was
wenn der regenbogen gar kein ende hat
[Musik]
regen würden sehen wie halbkreise aus
aber vom himmel aus gesehen sind sie
kreisrund das erkennt man nur vom
flugzeug aus sonst sehen wir nur die
hälfte des regenbogens weil der horizont
dazwischen kommt
vom flugzeug aus gesehen ist das nicht
der fall
[Musik]
vulkane sind faszinierende gebilde von
beinahe mystischer schönheit in
erloschenen zustand und buchstäblich
brandgefährlich wenn sie ausbrechen wir
kennen rund
1500 aktive vulkane sie zeigen wie sich
die erde permanent neu gestaltet
es ist schwer zu beschreiben was bei
einem vulkanausbruch passiert im grunde
entsteht ein neues stück erde vor
unseren augen
das ist adrenalin pur aber wenn es
richtig abgeht möchte man nicht in der
nähe sein
während eines urlaubs auf
papua-neuguinea werden touristen von
einem der denkwürdigsten
vulkanausbrüche überrascht die je
gefilmt wurden
das sind die unglaublichsten aufnahmen
eines vulkanausbruchs die ich je gesehen
habe
wenn man sorgfältig hinschaut sieht man
oben im bild eine weiße wolke die sich
ausbreitet das bedeutet dass die
teilchen während des vulkanausbruchs
schneller waren als der schall und ein
überschallknall bevorsteht
ein überschallknall wird erzeugt wenn
eine schockwelle schneller ist als die
schallgeschwindigkeit die liegt bei etwa
1200 kilometern pro stunde
vielleicht kommt der knall
heiliges kanonenrohr
das tolle an diesem kleinen video ist
dass wir beides haben die
lichtgeschwindigkeit
und die schallgeschwindigkeit
der vulkan liegt direkt am wasser das
wasser steuert gas und zusätzliches
material zur explosion bei man nennt das
eine hydro magnetische oder kroatische
vulkan explosion
vielleicht ist der vulkan explodiert
weil es zu viel wasser aufgenommen hat
er hat sich praktisch den weg frei
gerüstet nach der explosion schleuderte
der vulkan noch mehrere tage lang
material in die atmosphäre
glücklicherweise wird niemand verletzt
[Musik]
5000 kilometer weiter nördlich in japan
bricht 2013 der vulkan sakura china aus
er schleudert nicht nur asche sondern
auch blitze
blitze sind eigentlich teil eines
gewitters sie benötigen elektrische
spannung bei vulkanen ist das etwas sehr
seltenes
bei einem gewitter wird die blitze durch
unterkühlte regentropfen und eispartikel
ausgelöst in diesem fall entstanden die
blitze durch den aschestaub
felsgestein kleine staub und asche
partikel sowie hitze all das muss
zusammenkommen um blitze zu erzeugen
die partikel laden sich während der
eruption elektrisch aufstoßen mit großer
kraft zusammen und entladen sich wieder
manche werden positiv andere negativ und
plötzlich ist der unterschied groß genug
um blitze auszulösen
mit mehr als 1.000 eruptionen im jahr
zählt der sakura jima zu den aktivsten
vulkanen der welt
experten schätzen dass eine magmakammer
zu 90 prozent gefüllt ist folglich kann
sich jeden moment eine große explosion
ereignen
was ist furchteinflößender als ein
vulkanausbruch kombiniert mit blitzen
wie wäre es mit einer eruption die eine
kettenreaktion mit verschiedenen
unwetter auslöst so etwas ereignet sich
2013 in indonesien als der vulkan
sinabung ausbricht da finden so viele
naturkatastrophen gleichzeitig statt
dass es schwierig ist sie alle zu
benennen
die explosion wird eine lawine auslösen
das pyroklastischen material das an den
seiten runter rollt heizt den boden auf
so entstehen diese jubelnden massen
ein richtiger tornado formt sich von
oben nach unten diese hier macht es
umgekehrt weil heiße luft aus dem lava
floss aufsteigt er endet also eher einem
kleinen staub teufel steht aber nicht
aus staub sondern aus geschmolzenem
gestein
die vorstellung vor ort zu sein wenn
sich diese art von pyroklastischen
strömen gießt und sich solche
feuerteufel erheben ist beängstigend sie
blinzelt nur kurz und schon sind sie da
da gibt es kein entkommen game over
derzeit sind rund
1500 aktive vulkane bekannt in den
ozeanen werden zigtausende weitere
vermutet
raten sie mal wo sich der größte
bekannte vulkan überhaupt befindet
auf der erde gibt es gewaltige vulkane
aber ein noch größerer befindet sich auf
dem mars er heißt olympus mons hat einen
durchmesser von 600 kilometern und ist
25 kilometer hoch und
der größte vulkan der erde
das ist das tarot massiv im pazifik es
nimmt ein gebiet von 300 tausend
quadratkilometern ein und ist damit fast
so groß wie deutschland und nur etwas
kleiner als olympus mons
im pazifik gibt es mehr vulkane als
irgendwo sonst auf der erde kürzlich
gelang es einigen wissenschaftlern mit
einem ferngesteuerten
unterwasserfahrzeug die bislang tiefste
vulkaneruptionen aufzuzeichnen
eineinhalb kilometer unter der
meeresoberfläche
die aufnahmen stammen vom west martha
vulkan der 2009 im pazifischen ozean
entdeckt wurde
versetzen sie sich mal ein oder zwei
kilometer unter die meeresoberfläche
das ist eine welt der finsternis in der
nicht viel passiert wirklich bedrückend
und trotzdem schießt dieses ding
regelmäßig kleine feuerwerke ins meer
unter wasser werden eruptionen von
demselben phänomen ausgelöst wie an land
tektonische platten schieben sich
übereinander und erzeugen spannung und
druck was die erdkruste zum schmelzen
bringt und nach oben schiebt west mata
produziert extrem heiße lava sie wird
als bono nie bezeichnet und wurde
bislang nur bei längst erloschenen
vulkanen entdeckt
in dem video sieht man weißen dampf das
wasser kommt mit lover an kontakt die
bis zu 1000 grad heiß ist
es ist faszinierend wie hier die
gegensätze aufeinanderprallen das sieht
man nicht alle tage wasser und vorher
sie kennen die bilder der verwüstung die
tornados in den usa hinterlassen haben
aber solch wahnwitzige wirbel haben sie
vermutlich noch nicht gesehen
auf dieser rinderfarm in australien
bietet mehrere tage lang ein buschfeuer
und erzeugt ein phänomen das den
spitznamen
verträgt ein rasant drehender wirbel ein
feuertornado
es sieht aus als würde sich die halle
auftun
feuer tornados entstehen wenn sich die
enorme hitze der buschbrände mit dem
wind zu luft wirbeln verbindet das
ergebnis ist ein wirbelsturm der flammen
und asche nach oben zieht
wenn alles zusammenpasst treffen diese
heißen taschen mit scherben zusammen und
dann entsteht ein feuertornado
das faszinierende daran ist die
kombination aus wind und feuer
vor tornados gibt es nicht nur in
australien
dieser hier entstand nachdem ein blitz
in jim beam lager in kentucky
eingeschlagen hat das feuer sorgt dafür
dass drei millionen liter bourbon
whiskey in ein nahegelegenes
auffangbecken laufen und plötzlich
geschieht das unglaubliche die flammen
wirbeln über dem wasser
[Musik]
für so etwas müssen die voraussetzungen
stimmen du brauchst einen see damit
nicht alles drumherum feuer fängt du
brauchst alkohol auf dem see damit das
feuer genug brennstoff kriegt feuer und
wasser passen ja sonst nicht zusammen
und du braucht die richtigen bedingungen
für einen tornado aus meteorologischer
sicht ergibt das alles keinen sinn und
erscheint total unwirklich
das feuer kann schließlich gelöscht
werden der alkohol erweist sich als so
giftig dass fast alle fische in den
angrenzenden gewässern ums leben kommen
champion beteiligt sich mit 27.000
dollar an den kosten für die löschaktion
wenn tornados über dem wasser entstehen
wird es gefährlich wie hier 2011 einen
kilometer vor der küste north carolinas
jetzt ist sie noch massiver geworden
das ist eine riesige wasserhose
ich liebe solche aufnahmen man kann den
wirbel und die zirkulation sehr gut
sehen
eine wasserhose ist im grunde ein
tornado über wasser wenn sie auf land
trifft bezeichnen wir sie als tornado da
gibt es keinen unterschied dieses video
ist großartig weil es so nah dran ist
das sieht man nicht oft
sie kommt immer näher
viel näher
wir haben besser ab
man sieht viele leute wie sie einfach am
strand sitzen und das spektakel
bewundern oh
mein gott seht euch die leute an sind
das sonnenschirme nein das sind menschen
sind die verrückt
müssen wir ins auto
sieht aus als ob sie sich auflöst
die meisten leute halten wasser hosen
für ungefährlich sie glauben dass sie
auf dem wasser bleiben sie kommen aber
durchaus bis zum strand und stellen eine
große gefahr dar
als die leute endlich los rennen ist es
schon fast zu spät sie versuchen ihr
zurück aufzuheben und ihre kinder
einzusammeln
ich glaube du sagtest reinkommen wir
sind drin
alles was rumliegt wird zerfetzt im sand
bilden sich streifen unglaublich wie man
diese leute dran sind wäre sie das
filmen das ist ein wirklich heftiger
tornado
[Musik]
er hört sich nicht er geht in diese
richtung sie sagt ist das dein ernst com
du weißt nicht in welche richtung er
sich dreht er zieht daran das richtige
ist jetzt weg von den fenstern und ab in
deckung so ein wirbelsturm ist nicht nur
innerhalb des wirbels gefährlich da
waren sich unsere stühle zum glück wird
das paar auf dem balkon nicht voll
erwischt der tornado verursacht nur
geringe schäden und löst sich
schließlich auf
der katastrophenfilm schork nadeau aus
dem jahr 2013 hat uns mit einem weiteren
stürmischen phänomen vertraut gemacht
[Musik]
ok noch sind keine haie vom himmel
gefallen frösche und fische hat es
dagegen tatsächlich schon geregnet
im auge des tornados existierte ein
kräftiger auftrieb wir können alles
hochheben warum denn nicht das wasser
aus seinem sehen wenn es darin fische
oder frösche gibt gibt ja die gleich mit
aus dem wasser er nimmt sie hier auf
zieht weiter und lässt sie da wieder
herab regnen ganz schön beeindruckend
fliegende heil gibt es dagegen fürs
erste nur im fernsehen zu sehen
wie lange gibt es heuer schon bislang
sind sie wirbelstürmen erfolgreich aus
dem weg gegangen und das wird wohl auch
in zukunft so bleiben
die niagara fälle gehören zu den am
meisten fotografierten
naturwundern der erde es bedarf schon
eines besonders eisigen winters um sie
bis zur unkenntlichkeit zu verwandeln
was das winterwetter betrifft besser
geht's nicht
[Musik]
damit so etwas gewaltiges wie die
niagarafälle einfriert muss es schon
verdammt kalt sein
im februar 2015 liegen die temperaturen
weit unter dem durchschnitt die
tiefstwerte erreichen minus 14 grad das
ist kalt genug um das tosende wasser in
eine eiswand zu verwandeln
[Musik]
es war der kälteste februar in der
niagara region seit beginn der
wetteraufzeichnungen so konnten diese
skulpturen entstehen es war ein
fantastisches gigantisches schauspiel
in solch extremen wintern binden sich
bis zu 15 meter dicke eisschollen und
gefrorener nebel der alles einhüllt
[Musik]
auch wenn es aussieht als wäre alles
komplett zugefroren ist es nur der nebel
der woche für woche ganz unten gefriert
so baut sich im lauf der zeit eine ice
brücke am fuß der fälle auf die felsen
sind komplett mit eis bedeckt das wasser
hört aber nie ganz auf zufließen
es ist erstaunlich welche macht der
winter entwickelt wie viel wasser
gefriert wenn es lange genug kalt ist
wie viel von den niagarafällen kann
tatsächlich einfrieren
die niagara fälle werden nie vollständig
zu frieren dafür ist einfach zu viel
wasser in bewegung
[Musik]
angeblich waren die wasserfälle vor 100
jahren mal zugefroren tatsächlich gibt
es fotos auf denen menschen am rand der
fälle entlang spazieren
es sieht zwar komplett zugefroren aus
aber wahrscheinlich war das eine 1
brücke darunter floss immer noch wasser
durch nur nicht so viel wie sonst
egal wie kalt es ist die niagarafälle
werden niemals komplett zu frieren
manchmal muss man nur zur richtigen zeit
am richtigen ort sein und die ganze
schönheit des winters einzufangen wie
der mann aus north dakota der diese
bilder aufnahm
das ist eine scheibe in cheyenne rüber
wenn man genau hinsieht erkennt man dass
sie sich ganz langsam dreht
so ein riesiger habe ich noch nie
gesehen ziemlich großer durchmesser sehr
selten an
[Musik]
dieser stelle des flusses gibt es
vermutlich einen sehr langsamen strudel
das eis kann gar nicht anders als sich
im kreis zu drehen
das bestätigt einmal mehr dass die natur
die beste künstlerin der welt ist
manchmal bringt der winter auch beinahe
unerklärliche phänomene hervor wie diese
seltenen schnee ringel die in ohio
gesichtet wurden
sie sehen aus wie heuballen die auf dem
feld zusammen gerollt wurden
[Musik]
der wind lebt ein stück von der
schneedecke ab und rollt es langsam auf
während er sich immer weiter dreht nimmt
es schnee auf bis es fast wie eine spule
aussieht
irgendwann sind sie so groß dass der
wind sie nicht weiter bewegen kann dann
bleiben sie einfach liegen
hier ist extremer winter der normalfall
im sibirischen dorf im nacken im
vermutlich kältesten bewohnten ort der
welt zahl der einwohner 500
[Musik]
dieses gold so ist das kalt minus 50
grad
minus 50 grad celsius das ist wirklich
verdammt kalt
können sie bitte richtung kamera atmen
damit wir sehen wie kalt es ist
ja danke
die luft ist kalt und regelrecht ich bei
solchen temperaturen gibt es kaum schnee
oder eisregen
sogar beim ausatmen gefriert die luft so
trocken und kalt ist es da draußen
nachts wird es noch kälter
bei wintertemperaturen von minus 50 grad
fällt sogar das atmen schwer die
einheimischen müssen vorkehrungen
treffen um unterkühlung und erfrierungen
zu vermeiden
innerhalb von sekunden bekommt man
erfrierungen
von super zellen bis zu diesen
gigantischen wolken die welt des wetters
ist ständig im wandel
heiliges kanonenrohr
du kannst das wetter jahre lang
studieren und lernst trotzdem ständig
dazu es gibt immer was zu staunen
das wetter kann uns überraschen es kann
uns in atem halten und was am
wichtigsten ist es kann einblicke in die
größten geheimnisse des lebens geben